salut c'est hugo j'espère que vous allez
bien alors vous avez été très très
nombreux à suivre nos interviews face
cachée des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
en fait quand on cumule les différents
réseaux sociaux chaque interview de tous
les candidats a fait plusieurs millions
de vues alors forcément déjà je tient
évidemment à vous remercier pour votre
confiance parce que là c'est un travail
et on va en parler qui forcément très
très important de préparation à tous
points de vue et donc pas de voir ce
travail reconnu et autant suivi se fait
forcément plaisir et c'est un signe de
confiance donc merci beaucoup pour votre
confiance là dessus vous avez posé
beaucoup de questions ces derniers jours
sur les interviews qui ont été réalisés
mais aussi sur les interviews qui n'ont
pas été réalisés je vais répondre
aujourd'hui sachant que je voulais en
profiter pour vous dire deux petites
choses quand même avant de commencer
d'abord première chose je ferai une
autre faq plus complète et aussi de
présentation de nos bureaux etc de notre
studio de tournage aussi comme promis
c'est sortira dans cette sur cette même
chaîne youtube dans quelques jours donc
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner thiam s est
pas encore le cas pour ne pas louper ça
et puis par ailleurs je tiens à vous
annoncer ça ça fait très très plaisir
qu'on va avoir notre propre soirée
électorale notre propre live de soirée
électorale ça se passe directement sur
ma chaîne twitch et donc concrètement je
serai en live avec des invités à partir
de 16h et jusqu'à la fin de la soirée on
a fait le choix de ne pas avoir de
personnalités politiques mais plutôt à
voir et bien des chercheurs des
journalistes et même vous en faites qui
vont être aussi à présent partie sur le
plateau mais aussi évidemment dans le
chat pour répondre à un maximum de vos
questions avoir des débats les sujets
suivre en direct et bien l' annonce des
résultats évidemment inventeur mais
aussi les différentes réactions des
politiques ensuite elle suivre cette
journée électorale avec vous comme on a
suivi le reste de la présidentielle
aussi avec vous c'est vers les jours de
rendez vous donc dimanche on peut
commencer sans plus tarder avec la
petite faq leur première question est ce
que certains avaient des exigences sur
des sujets à évoquer ou à ne pas évoquer
alors oui dans son sous certains avaient
tenté de formuler comme ça des exigences
sur des sujets à évoquer ou non
maintenant notre côté on a fait le choix
est bien de ne pas accepter ce genre de
contraintes par rapport au format en
fait on avait un format que vous voyez
maintenant qui est le format donc des
interviews face cachée on avait ce
format là ont volé s'en tenir à ce
format là et que tous les candidats
passent avec le même format on savait en
fait que d'autres moments c'était une
porte ouverte à une discussion une
négociation sur chaque question ou
autres avec eux tous les candidats et
donc on voulait surtout pas rentrer là
dedans donc on a dit voilà il ya ce
format et les candidats qui veulent
participer peuvent participer on va pas
rentrer dans les détails après ça
rejoint d'ailleurs la deuxième question
ce sera très rapide est ce que les
candidats connaissait les questions à
l'avancé la réponse du coup c'est non il
les connaissait pas à l'avant ce même
s'ils peuvent forcément s'y préparer
l'interview est bien se douter que ben
ils vont parler un public qui est plus
jeune que le public en général qu'ils
ont à la télé ou autre donc certains
sujets risquent d'être davantage présent
et non sinon il n'avait pas du tout les
questions à l'avancé on leur envoyait
pas alors autres questions où je tenais
vraiment à y répondre parce que j'essaie
d'y répondre à chaque fois que je fais
une faq où toutes sortes de choses quand
j'explique un peu les coulisses de notre
travail et la façon dont on voit ça me
paraît essentiel c'est la question de la
neutralité et de l'objectivité répondons
à la chose directement la neutralité ou
l'objectivité en soit dans le
journalisme c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas et ça peut paraître bizarre
de dire ça comme ça mais les
journalistes quel qu'il soit ce ne sont
pas des robots et en fait on peut
vouloir est ce qu'on essaie de faire
évidemment un journalisme qui se veut et
bien honnête factuel etc mais le simple
fait par exemple de poser une question
plutôt qu'une autre à un candidat ou aux
différents candidats à la présidentielle
c'est une absence de neutralité c'est un
parti pris éditorial disons et c'est
bien normal d'ailleurs mais ça montre
bien qu aucun journaliste ne peut être
neutre ou à leurs objectifs donc voilà
on parle beaucoup vous l'avez vu des
sujets environnementaux par exemple et
de ce sujet du climat par exemple passer
un choix éditorial de le faire et c'est
qu'on considère que c'est un sujet
majeur qui doit être portée au quotidien
de la même façon on parle beaucoup là
vous l'avez vu dans les interviews de la
détresse économique de nombreux jeunes
de la situation notamment de la jeunesse
alors ça tient évidemment au fait que
vous êtes nombreux à être jeunes et à
suivre ce qu'on fait y a pas que des
jeunes n'y a quand même pas mal de
jeunes qui jouent qui nous suivent
aujourd'hui et donc ça fait que c'est un
sujet pareil comporte beaucoup c'est ce
qui permet par ailleurs de faire
ressortir les positions des candidats et
aussi les lacunes de certains candidats
sur certains sujets précis qui nous
semble important alors autre question
qui est parvenu tant que ça mais je
voulais quand même y répondre
aujourd'hui les questions sont-elles
aléatoire l'immense majorité d'entre
vous l'a bien compris je pense que c'est
pour ça que la question n'ait pas
beaucoup revenu dans la faq c'est assez
évident évidemment les questions ne sont
pas aléatoires aujourd'hui pour la
simple et bonne raison que alors on doit
préparer l'interview est donc pour
préparer l'interview on doit préparer
aussi les questions alors maintenant il
ya une question sur l'ordre d'apparition
des questions lors de l'interview est là
en fait ça a été des grosses discussions
au sein de l'équipe pour arriver à
trouver le meilleur modèle en fait par
rapport aux interviews des candidats
parce que l'inde avait plusieurs options
la première option serait de se dire on
va préparer vingt ou trente questions et
on va en garder que 10 lors de
l'interview et donc aléatoirement ça va
s'arrêter sur une main sur dix des
trente questions qu'on a préparé la
vente âge de ça c'est qu'il y avait un
côté aléatoire donc tous et cette
mécanique là le désavantage c'est que
l'on perde et je trouve beaucoup de
contrôles en fait sur l'interview or
justement du point de vue de notre
responsabilité se dire que ça se trouve
on va passer à côté des cinq questions
les plus importantes qu'il faut selon
nous poser absolument aux candidats pas
ça pose quand même problème de se dire
bah c'est le hasard donc tant pis on
posera pas telle ou telle question donc
ça on a écarté assez rapidement l'option
après on avait une autre option qui
était de se dire bah on ajoute une part
d'aléatoire mais en fait la première et
la dernière question pour ont cadré
qu'alain pauline tard joue on le garde
et ça on s'est du coup quelle question
tombe on trouvait que c'était un peu
bizarre cet entre-deux et donc au final
on s'est dit bon bah tant pis non on ne
sait pas aléatoire et d'ailleurs on ne
dit pas vous le voyez à andy pas du tout
que ce quelque chose d'aléatoire on
explique juste le fonctionnement de
l'interview non c'est moi je sais les
questions qui arrive est en fait ce que
ça permet c'est d'avoir un vrai contrôle
éditorial sur l'interview pour poser les
questions qui sont les plus importantes
mais par contre le format reste pour
autant je trouve très intéressant et je
les ai vus aussi avec vos retours ça
reste quelque chose qui est ludique qui
est innovant ce que ça permet notamment
je trouve ces sept deux surprises pour
pour vous mais même pour surtout même
pour le candidat qui voit les bogies
cadeau qui s'apprête à découvrir du coup
derrière c'était magique à dos une
question qu'il garde un autre candidat
enfin il ya ce côté aléatoire je trouve
avec le dévoilement de choses à l'écran
qui ajoute vraiment quelque chose et ça
on tenait à la voir absolument parce que
c'est une façon si je pense d'approcher
les candidats et d'approcher les
questions qui est nouvelle et donc voilà
comment est ce que cette question a été
tranchée alors autre question là aussi
beaucoup revenus comment gères-tu le
temps de parole c'est une question qui
est majeure parce qu en fait faut
comprendre que en ligne aujourd'hui sur
internet on n'est pas contrôlée par le
csa où l'art comme aujourd'hui comme le
sont la télévision la radio qui on a
d'abord une imposition d'équité de temps
de parole ou en fait il ya un
déséquilibre entre les candidats en
fonction des sondages et des derniers
résultats aux élections et puis quelques
jours avant l'élection d'égalité très
strictes de ton parole de l'autre côté
sur internet en théorie on fait ce qu'on
veut c'est à dire qu' on aurait pu faire
3 3 heures d'interviews d'un candidat
dix minutes d'un autre et faire ça comme
on veut sur youtube pour autant donc
vous l'avez vu nous on a choisi d'avoir
une égalité de temps de parole entre
tous les candidats quels que soient leur
pourcentage dans les sondages ou quoi
que ce soit même un candidat qui a un
pour cent bien à autant de temps de
parole qu un candidat qui est à 20%
disons dans les sondages ça me semblait
une bonne chose à faire alors après d'un
point de vue très concret certains
peuvent se demander mais si certaines
interviews ont duré plus longtemps que
d'autres comment est ce que vous faites
c'est très simple on a fait en sorte
d'avoir bas au montage d'équilibré tout
ça certaines interviews parfois duré dix
minutes de plus que d'autres et du coup
nous en sorte de raccourcir tout en
gardant évidemment le fond et la teneur
des différentes choses pas de raccourcir
l'interview pour qu'on atteigne plus ou
moins de trois minutes présent à une
égalité entre tous les candidats et
voilà du coup comment est-ce qu'on a
procédé autre question as tu senti un
comportement particulier de leur part
parce que tu es jeune que son audience
l'êtes aussi et que c'est diffusé sur
internet déjà premier point là-dessus
certains candidats étaient surpris qu'on
parle de fond on parle de leur vision de
la france du programme etc je pense que
certains s'attendaient à ce que vu qu'on
est sur internet forcément ça allait
être des sujets léger du divertissement
quoi que ce soit pas non ça n'a pas été
le cas on a parlé de sujets de fond ça
ressemblait d'ailleurs essentiel voulu
imaginer de le faire par ailleurs il ya
certains candidats mais ça vous l'avez
vu aussi lors de l'interview qui ont
parfois tenté un peu de me ramener à mon
âge alors que ce soit d'ailleurs façon
négative ou autre mais c'est parfois
ressorti par moments le fait de ramener
comme ça à mon âge je sais notamment
qu'ils aient eu à la séquence une
séquence qui a beaucoup circulé sur tik
tok et sur twitter lorsque j'étais face
à eric zemmour peut-on espérer
rassembler les français en tant que
président de la république après
plusieurs condamnations justement pour
provocation à la haine
jeune homme ce genre de choses ça
arrivait parfois avec quelques candidats
pas tous évidemment mais ça arrive et
qu'elle aime et avec certains à titre
personnel je réponde c'est pas dessus
parce que ça ne semblait pas forcément
important sur le fond et surtout les
gens me voyaient déjà donc ça serve à
rien de le relever on a vu beaucoup de
commentaires en réaction à tous et
toutes là donc les jantes façon on était
conscient et oui moi je considère dubout
que l'âge n'a rien à voir avec le
sérieux d'une interview c'est à dire
qu'on peut avoir 25 ans et faire une
interview catastrophique comme une très
bonne interview et même chose à 70 ans
donc donc voilà comment ce que je vois
le sujet alors une négation aussi qu'ils
aient beaucoup revenu à laquelle je
voulais apprendre le temps de répondre
aujourd'hui pourquoi est ce qu'il n'ya
pas eu des interviews de emmanuel macron
ou encore de valérie pécresse alors pour
vale pécresse ça va être très rapide sur
l'explication on avait une date de
calais en fait en février c'est une date
qu'ils ont finalement décalé ils ont pas
réussi à trouver de créneau alors qu'on
leur avait proposé normalement de
créneaux et puis un an plus tard elle a
eu le colisée puis moi je suis tombé
malade et puis elle a été en déplacement
notamment aux ans et bref pour résumer
et n'ont pas réussi à trouver un créneau
pour le faire malgré les très nombreuses
propositions qu'on l'aura fait donc
voilà du coup vous l'aurez remarqué pas
d'interview de valérie pécresse sur la
chaîne alors pour ce qui est des manuels
macron désormais déjà la première chose
à comprendre enfin je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure et ça va aller pour tous les
candidats c'est que l'on tenait et on
tient encore à faire le même format pour
tous les candidats dans le cas très
précis dernier le maquereau déjà il a
été candidat plus tardivement que les
autres ce qui fait que il y en avait un
peu moins de temps forcément pour calais
cette interview par ailleurs vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que quand s'est déclaré
candidat et bien y avait en parallèle la
guerre il ya encore en parallèle la
guerre en ukraine et donc lui il est à
la fois candidat à la présidentielle est
à la fois aussi vous le savez forcément
encore président de la république avec
ses crises à gérer donc la raison qui a
été beaucoup invoqué ces derniers jours
par l'équipe de campagne c'est une
raison de contraintes d'agenda et
d'indisponibilité pour caler la date et
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut entendre
en soi puisque justement à l'actualité
forcément chargé et en même temps moi ça
me semble assez essentiel de venir
répondre à des questions qui concernent
justement notre génération surtout que
vous êtes parfois assez nombreux à
regarder nos interviews des candidats à
la présidentielle mais a pas regardés
forcément d'autres interviews dans
d'autres médias mais nous scénario qui
n'est pas tournée en direct donc on peut
en soi est ce qu'on a dit la tournée
littéralement quasiment tout le temps et
on peut s'adapter pour faire en sorte de
le faire comme on a fait avec les autres
candidats à tout moment et ça en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas le cas dans
certains nombres d'une interview qu'a
donnée emmanuel macron qui était au jt
de 20 heures cette semaine sur tf1 qui
était sur france inter cette semaine qui
était sur m6 qui était sur pas mal
d'autres médias plus traditionnels
disons voilà pour tout vous dire moi je
trouve à titre personnel que c'est
vraiment dommage parce que ça aurait
vraiment apporter quelque chose la même
façon qu'on l'a fait pour les autres
candidats d'avoir ce temps des changes
sur ces sujets qui sont absolument
majeur attend une question qui se pose
est ce une question un peu ouverte que
je pose même avoué je vous invite
vraiment un parallèle éventuellement
dans les commentaires la question qu'on
se pose c'est que si jamais c'est une
question de timing et d'agenda bah en
fait si on se dit que l'on fait
éventuellement l'interview lors du
second tour dans le cas où emmanuel
macron est au second tour rien n'est sûr
mais enfin y'a quand même des chances
qu'il soit au second tour est ce que eh
bien on pourrait pas faire cette
interview lors du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle la question
que se pose en fait c'est est ce que
c'est égalité entre les différents
candidats que emmanuel macron soit
interviewé au second tour certains
pourraient dire que c'est avantageux
pour lui mais d'autres pourrait dire que
c'est aussi à son désavantage parce
qu'en fait alors dans le cas où emmanuel
macron et au second tour et que coup on
line interview au second tour et qui les
acceptent etc etc en fait certaines
interviews et diffuser plus tardivement
mais c'est aussi un désavantage dans le
sens où l'interview de l'autre candidat
ou candidate à la présidentielle au
second tour aura été postés sur notre
chaîne depuis des semaines déjà elle
aura déjà eu le temps de faire
potentiellement des millions et des
millions de vues et donc au final c'est
pas forcément un avantage pour emmanuel
macron des diffusé tardivement puisque
ça laisse moins de temps aux gens pour
voir cette interview voilà donc pour mes
réponses aux questions les plus hauts
revenus concernant cette interview c'est
une interview pardon face cachée des
candidats à la présidentielle tom semble
essentiel de faire ce petit travail
quand même aujourd'hui à quelques jours
du vote et donc vous allez pouvoir
suivre la soirée électorale avec nous
dimanche je le disais aussi par ailleurs
mais vous êtes sûrement déjà au courant
sur instagram on a des formats de
résumés des programmes de tous les
candidats de comparaison des positions
des candidats sur pas mal de sujets
aussi importants c'est très nombreux à
nous suivre sur instagram servir du jour
voilà on essaie de faire le travail au
mieux et pourtour encore une fois fait
très très plaisir le prenez soin de vous
présent vos proches et voilà qu on se
dit du coup à très vite pour d'autres
vidéos sur sa chaîne on fera d'ailleurs
d'autres vidéos qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la présidentielle dans les
prochains jours ça me semble assez
essentiel et je peux notamment vous
utilisez que la semaine prochaine on
aura l'interview d'un artiste que vous
connaissez sans aucun doute qu'il sera
présent du coup sur cette même chaîne
youtube et évidemment du coup on se
donne rendez-vous à d'immenses sur
twitch
[Musique]